what is your take on the statement
filmmaking is not art
[Music]
i mean it's uh
where oh
that's a lot okay um
um so um
um for those that are new here my name
is dan mace and
this is my youtube channel so make sure
to hit that subscribe button because i
have something really special in store
for you today
for youtube filmmakers versus four movie
directors
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video which is the complete stock
solution for creators and businesses
alike providing an unlimited library of
high quality royalty-free
video audio and images through
cost-effective subscription plans
i use them all the time so if you
support me go over and click on the link
below to support them too
okay filmmaking the filmmaker what is
that what does it actually mean
is it somebody who merely goes out and
purchases a camera and starts shooting
stuff
or is there a separation between a more
certified term
like a director cinematographer that the
more qualified filmmakers
on youtube don't have the luxury of the
title or
job description this intrigues me
because i've existed in both worlds
first
on the film directing side of things
which was extremely
exhilarating and then i moved over to
youtube which was equally
as stimulating but now i've been offered
a really terrifying yet
massive opportunity back in the
traditional directing sphere
which at the end of this video depending
on the answers that i get
i will reveal my next moves as a
i don't even know what to describe it as
and beyond that
does it even matter therefore the only
way to do this is to get eight
highly accomplished filmmakers four of
my favorite youtubers
[Music]
story
[Music]
and four of my favorite film directors
so
and ask them one really introspective
difficult question that rids the amount
of followers the awards
the pedestal that may have come with the
pathway they have decided to pursue
which is based on a discussion i
recently came across on quora with
millions of responses that were very
equally weighted
on the idea that filmmaking is not art
now
personally i side with the idea that
filmmaking is
most definitely an art form but i want
to pose the statement
to huge influences and mentors of mine
because for one the shock factor in the
offense of the statements filmmaking is
not
art with no context would evoke the most
authentic and passion driven response no
matter if there
are youtube filmmakers or titled
award-winning directors
all these filmmakers thought i was just
calling them for a catch-up chat
how's it going dude what's up bro what's
up dan how are you
hello yo tris how are you doing fred
until i randomly said what is your take
on the statement
filmmaking is not art i think it's a
stupid statement
just my gut reaction is that's that's
dumb i think any sort of form of
creative expression is
is art i think it's quite complex
because i think it's it's inherently
subjective
to evoke emotion i believe is an art
form in itself
i've never seen myself as an artist it
might be weird because i couldn't create
what i've created without the artists
that have created it with me
and because of this not only do i think
that filmmaking
is an art i think it's honestly one of
the most powerful art forms out there
if you're a youtuber a director if
you've made one commercial if you've
made
a feature documentary or felt like when
it comes to video there's so many things
that has to
come together arts evolve right like if
you look at
art in history it seems to be about that
it seems to be a way that the person
interrogates they're in a landscape
creativity by definition is about
you know an individual's expression
of ideas or feelings the idea that
that expression is going to be
universally understood and appreciated
is absurd i do think that is some
filmmaking that is an
artist some filmmaking that is commerce
the end goal is to get
butts in seats and i understand that i
think the industries that can can be
really tough in that it like demands us
to
choose certain categories or platforms
or
directions and i just don't think that
that's helpful or healthy
in a world where we want to encourage
more and more filmmakers to like
participate in the medium we want to
democratize filmmaking
executive producers want big name talent
in the film because big name talent has
a draw
perhaps working a little bit
counter-intuitive to again
for this particular film that i want to
make i want it to be transparent i don't
want you to see
that name in that name i have to
compromise so i think for me
that is one of the words that would
start to define the blurring of the line
between when you go into
something that you're trying to make for
it's like purity or for its artistic
integrity and something that's supposed
to
get as many people to see it and for its
commerce
aspect you have to be willing to do it
just how much
i remember i wrote a letter to go to a
film school and they said why do you
want to become a filmmaker and i wrote
because i want to move people the same
way that i was moved by their particular
pieces of work if you look at which
movies
win the academy award for best picture
best director or whatever it is
and then you look at the movies that the
most people paid money to go see
they very rarely align because the
critics
whose job it is to assess good from bad
they think those movies sucked
but people like those movies and people
think those movies are so good they're
willing to pay 15
to go see them focusing on what is art
and what isn't art
is kind of a distraction because i think
i couldn't express myself as a person
growing up
and filmmaking was gave me that voice to
express myself
you know to me that's what this art form
has enabled me to do it's enabled me to
convey this emotion that i've
experienced in my life which was
losing my brother and and share that
perspective with
with the rest of the world and it takes
some grit you know no matter
who you are art is hard to make as a job
so
you're gonna have a taller hill to climb
and that's why i embrace the title
of being a youtuber and i i have no
desire
to pursue a title that has greater
pretense
it feels like it has more integrity to
me
than trying to court the favor of a
handful of critics
i i don't i don't work on sets i don't
work with
50 to 100 person crews making films like
i
work with myself and an editor so you
asked if i was doing some commercial
work lately if i was going more
traditional
i was hired by a massive automotive
company to do
their entire holiday campaign and
there's normally an agency involved they
were all
shocked when they heard that this
automotive company had chosen a youtuber
to shoot this whole campaign so here i
was on set
with 50 people mostly getting the
feeling
personally that they didn't like me or
they knew i didn't know what i was doing
but i'm coming at it from a totally
different world where
art is expressed differently it's
created in a different way
it's less systematic like i don't think
either way is wrong i don't think either
side is wrong i think there's just
different paths to get to the same goal
i don't think there will be a difference
between a filmmaker and a youtube
filmmaker
it'll almost become your filmmaker the
platform now youtube is where
we're all going for our work to be seen
it means like a community and i think we
all contribute
like i think youtube filmmakers are
inspired by forms that they've seen in
theater and
people who are releasing films in
theaters certainly inspired by something
they see on their phones
the thing with youtube that's incredible
is it is it it is forcing your muscle to
work
constantly and that as a filmmaker is
kind of an amazing uh
an amazing platform for that and you and
you do it for for whatever reason you
started it for i mean
i don't really care if it's odd or not
at the end of the day we're just trying
we're all just trying to create stuff to
think like however you feel comfortable
creating
is correct perfect
so good to chat again yeah dude i'll
chat to you later for sure
thank you so much for your time we
appreciate it
after this it took a few days to absorb
the fact that the grass
isn't indeed greener on the other side
instead the artist of today drove the
lawnmower right through the [ __ ]
fence
and merged the two worlds that's where
we headed the coexistence a
merging of the traditional and
non-conformists
but before i reveal my my big news
i just want to talk about story blocks
because without brands like this i
wouldn't be able to make the films i
make and be in a position i
am today storyblocks is a long-term
sponsor and support for me
i can truly just say they make the
process of creating films so much easier
better
faster whether you consider it art or
not creating video
is about telling your story and they
make that possible even if you have
nothing but your laptop
with affordable access to an unlimited
stock library
it elevates your level of production
quality especially if you don't have the
budget or access to the right locations
so go down to the link in the
description and sign up today to elevate
your video creation process
after those insightful and
passion-driven responses from such
established filmmakers
i finally made up my mind on um what the
next step is for me
i'm uh partnering well my team and i
are partnering up i'm pausing for a
dramatic effect
they have just announced their new
platform and it's called
discovery plus which is like netflix or
disney plus but on steroids
and i'm writing and directing some
incredible content for them before i say
anything that i'm
not allowed to say i'm tied up in a lot
of ndas i'm going to call the vp
of multi-platform at discovery tom
lofthouse who through this process has
really guided me and become just a
really good friend of mine
yo would you be able to jump on a zoom
call
how you doing man how are you i'm good
so i'm just doing a segment trying to
explain
what this is and i don't want to break
any
laws
dude i should have got my brew blank
here so yeah so gosh this has been like
a long time in the making but you know
discovery plus is going to be
the definitive home for real people with
real stories and i think that
you embody that extremely well down in
your storytelling process
so uh those are the types of stories
that i want to be telling you know yeah
i'm excited to be able to say that we're
going to be making some cool stuff
together dude
really embrace the style of filmmaking
that you know artists like yourself have
become
you know kind of almost like prolific
act it's like
it's taken the the best parts of both
sides
yes and merge them together and
i'm just so grateful for the opportunity
thank you of course man it's been an
amazing
journey of planning this stuff with you
and getting to know you so yeah man
thank you bro yeah of course man i'll
see you in a bit cheers dude
this all still feels like a complete
dream and
you know when i think back to where it
all began
these edits are the best
thing we've ever done the best
work we've ever done
and now i'm i'm gonna take the time to
just
absorb all that and uh so i'm not
leaving youtube
it's a coexistence it's the
there's a lot of great content to come
on the channel but i'm just going to
take some time off
not long a month at most so in the
meantime
merry christmas happy new year and
lastly don't forget
you're awesome brew and i'll see you on
the other side
[Music]